um
welcome uh welcome everyone to
uh the simon institute uh my name is
prasad raguedra i'm the senior scientist
at the institute uh the institute was
created in
2012 with a generous donation from the
simon's foundation and we've been
hosting programs uh two programs every
semester and this this semester we have
a program on computational complexity
statistical inference
and this one geometric methods and
optimization and sampling
and this is the last workshop of the
geometric methods and optimization
sampling program
a few logistic things before
we begin
so no snack or drinks inside the
auditorium
there are lockers available to
keep your store your bags
uh coffee will be served just outside
the
outside the building
and
we have asia around
be able to answer any questions you
might have logistic related and omid is
helping us with the video
um and
and so this workshop
um on optimization on symmetry
is organized by
nishiku vishnu michael walter and asia
wilson
uh thanks to nsf for
the support of both the programs and uh
and so without much to do i'll let
nishit vishnu
say a few words up of introduction to
the workshop
[Music]
can you hear me yes
okay thanks prasad uh for um
for this introduction and thanks to the
simon's institute for
their generosity uh allowing us to
organize this workshop
uh i'm really glad to report uh with
michael walter and asia wilson my
co-organizers
um organizing this workshop title
optimization under symmetry
um thanks to all of you who could make
it and
who are participating virtually from
various parts of the world despite
you know very different time zones but
this workshop will focus on uh some of
the recent trends
that we have been witnessing in the
design of optimization and sampling
algorithms in particular
once we hit a few non-convex
optimization and sampling problems it
was realized that
often
non-convexity can be bypassed by
using the underlying symmetries
and we will see several examples of
this meta approach in this workshop
where once we realize that there is a
symmetry group
typically a continuous symmetry group
that acts on the objective function or
the domain
then using
uh and synthesizing techniques from
geometry algebra analysis
one can come up with some really new and
interesting
results
uh computational results
and
so so this workshop will showcase
problems and
solutions from various domains including
theoretical computer science
discrete optimization quantum physics
statistics mathematics and machine
learning
and uh
melanie will be sharing the first
session so melanie it's
over to you
okay uh is the sound system working
i think it is okay great
um thanks everyone for coming and i'm
super grateful to be speaking here um
thanks prasad and shethan melanie um
so i'm gonna be talking about
uh
basically a cool connection between a
problem that i've been working on for a
long time along with a bunch of my
collaborators norm minimization
um with uh
some other topics
in particular quantum tomography
and this is not really much of an
optimization talk it's more of a
why might you care about this particular
optimization problem
because of its neat connections to other
things
so the first thing i'm going to talk
about is
just an example of quantum angular
momentum
then i'll talk about this
connection between invariant theory and
normalization
and also connection to tomography
and finally i'll mention this proof
outline of our
kind of result
and in the proof you can see that
there's some relation between
kind of a long-standing conjecture we
don't solve the conjecture or get
anywhere close to it but
i think the connection is kind of
promising
and then of course open directions
uh and there's also some closely this is
this is work with michael walter i
should have said there's some uh very
closely related work uh another group
did essentially the same thing with very
minor differences
um independently
okay
so uh
let's talk about angular momentum so i'm
not a quantum physicist by any means um
if you are please please stop me
uh and uh and feel free to ask questions
although i might not know the answers
okay so
imagine we have a bunch of copies of a
quantum particle and it's some state we
don't necessarily know the state
um
but we have a bunch of copies of it
and
we want to know
uh if we measure the total angular
momentum of this particle
uh what's the chance we get zero uh of
the of this
uh sort of ensemble of particles what's
the chance we get zero
um
now i don't know if you guys are
familiar but like quantum systems you
know
it's not a deterministic thing the
angular minimum
if you measure it you could get
any number um up to you know
the maximum angular minimum single
particle like times times k but
in general there's going to be some
distribution
so for intuition you can think of the
classical analog
if you have a bunch of plus minus one
random variables which are like weighted
you know probability p of plus one one
minus p of minus one
um
what's the chance that they sum to zero
this is a pretty easy problem and you
could think the connection is sort of
that pluses spin up
minus to spin down
um
and there's like these turn off bounds
which tell you
pretty much exactly what
you know the rate of decay of this is
happening like if p is
exactly 0.5 then you get basically like
one over root n
uh or one over root k i i've admitted
the polynomial factors here
i only care about the exponential ones
but if p is not 0.5 you get an
exponential decay um
okay and so the question is
you know
depending on what the state is
is the probability of measuring angular
minimum and the quantum case is going to
decay exponentially as well and what's
the rate of decay
so i'll tell you sort of the details um
or like the mathematical formalism of
what's going on it's not too important
you know for the rest of the talk if you
if you understand all the details
um
but uh we think of a particle as a unit
vector
in some representation of the
two-dimensional special unitary group
um
so that's two by two unitary matrices
with determinant one
and uh
you know
we write the action
of uh the group element on the vector as
g dot you know v
in the total angular minimum as i said
it's going to be some
random variable
lk
because there's k copies that's what the
k stands for and it's actually going to
take half integral values in the picture
i guess it's it's a it's multiplied by
uh
planck's constant but
um here i'm just going to take it to be
half an hour okay so here's what our
result says for this problem
so it says that
the limit of the chance uh of getting
zero
uh raised to the one over k
the reason you raised the one over k
here is because you expect some
exponential decay so you wanna know like
what is this exponential rate of decay
well it's equal to
a norm minimization problem over
the two by two matrices with determinant
one
so
i did
kind of pull a fast one here i said i
had an su-2
representation
but i extended it to sl2
um
i need some kind of technical conditions
to be able to do this but basically all
i need is that the representation i
began with was
uh you know a polynomial representation
so think of it as just finite
dimensional
anyway the point is you can express this
rate of decay
as
this uh
optimization problem and this is just
the euclidean norm that you're
optimizing over this group
so i think this is kind of neat um
and one thing this immediately tells you
um
well
it tells you that you can compute this
rate in
uh polynomial time
um this is the result of with
um
a bunch of my collaborators we work on
this particular type of optimization
problem and i think it's probably going
to appear a number of times in this
workshop
it's called the norm minimization
problem
and it happens to be
geodesically convex in the right
geometry
and uh and you can efficiently compute
it
you can't always if this group
here
was uh you know the dimension was
growing you can't necessarily compute it
efficiently but in this case you can
um
what else another thing you can say is
that
because the probability the rate of
decay is is this number
the only way that the
it's going to concentrate at zero is if
this number is one
so
the only way it will concentrate a zero
is if
this quantity is already minimized at
the identity um
and it's going to turn out that
the gradient of this function at the
identity will actually encode
these expected directional angular
momentum
so like the way it's going to work is
that
the only way you'll get concentration at
zero is if the expected angular momentum
are zero
of your state
okay
so it's like
you have a random variable that morally
has mean zero that's the only situation
that's gonna concentrate okay
so for the rest of the talk i'll tell
you um
kind of the connections with invariant
polynomials and normal minimization i
mean this one's sort of obvious
but i think this connection is a lot
less obvious that you can express this
probability
uh as something about invariant
polynomials
um okay
so i'm going to move on next to the
invariant polynomials
and uh maybe i'll ask do people have
questions at this point
all right
i took my
time
i started early
um
okay
so i guess we can except for the group
that's the only thing that we need to
kind of retain in our minds we can clear
clear everything from our minds we're
going to talk about invariance now
so
we'll have g being some sort of nice
group
acting on a complex vector space
so
basically always thinking about these
very concrete groups here uh the
invertible matrices that's gln sln
convertible matrices with determinant
one and products thereof uh technically
it's like
uh complex reductive groups that we're
going to worry about
here's an example you could have
the invertible matrices
acting on the space of n by and matrices
by conjugation
so there's there's a good example
and there's this classical theorem
of hilbert which says basically that
um
zero
is going to be in the closure of an
orbit
uh or he's not in the closure of an
orbit that's called being semi-stable
just jargon
if and only if
not every
invariant polynomial
vanishes on the point v
and uh
if every polynomial vanishes on uh
invariant polynomial vanishes on v
uh then we say that v is in the nullcha
again that's just sort of jargon for
those who
care about these kinds of problems
but uh
you know this is sort of an intuitive
thing one direction of it is very easy
you know if
zero is in the orbit closure
um
then every homogeneous invariant
polynomial must vanish on it because
these polynomials are continuous
so like they have to be zero on this
whole orbit because they're invariant
the cool thing about this theorem is
that it goes both ways um
so
yeah so this is just the
sort of technical
way of saying this this uh
is how we denote the degree k
uh invariant polynomials so they are
preserved by this action so so i should
just be careful and say
all that means is that if i have p v
here
and
i plug in g
that's not going to change the value of
the polynomial
another way is that these polynomials
take the same value across the group
orbits
so what we were curious about michael
and i
is whether there's a more quantitative
version of this theorem instead of just
saying that well
uh
zero is in the orbit closure if it only
if there's no polynomials what can you
say about how far it is from the orbit
closure and
maybe
how large these polynomials are
so one quantity we're going to care
about is the distance between
uh over the over closure to zero
and
the other quantity is
the magnitude of a random invariant
polynomial
so
we'll look at the uh
expected value of its you know
evaluation squared
and this is intentionally vague at this
moment
but this is always going to denote like
implicitly there's a degree around so
it's a random invariant of a certain
degree and i'll tell you how to
actually draw it but in your mind you
can at this point just think of it as
like
you know an invariant but with gaussian
coefficients
so this is the
connection we're going to be looking at
and here's our result um
we have that
this
magnitude
of a random invariant
evaluated in the
point vector v
is equal to
the minimum squared distance to the
orbit closure
so there's a pretty tight connection
between these things
the only thing that i'm slightly lying
about here is that
really this should be a limb soup
because
for some certain values of k there
aren't going to be any invariants but
all you need is that uh
you know k just has to be divisible by a
certain quantity it's all it's all the
constraint on k is is that
uh it's divisible so really this should
be like
k equals like
a times l for some l that's going to
infinity but
i've i've sort of
swept that under the rug in the notation
um
right so so i said i would say how to
select this polynomial
um
basically
this space it's a vector space
so you could take like a complex
gaussian on it really it's just any
uh any distribution that's isotropic it
doesn't really matter what it is
and the sense in which it should be
isotropic is
with respect to the bombieri norm
and i will explain what that is but
it's actually just a super common and
like very natural
inner product on on polymer males
um
and what about this norm
well i said it's just euclidean but
you have to specify a basis for that
uh
in general it's going to be uh sort of
an invariant inner product under some
like
compact subgroup
for example if g was gln then it should
be
uh you know u in invariant um inner
product but all the examples we're going
to look at today it's going to be
obvious what it is it's just going to be
the euclidean norm in some obvious basis
um
yeah so i said this already
okay
any questions
so to talk a little bit more about the
uh
like why we care about these quantities
um
this minimal norm quantity uh
has come up a bunch in in my research
and that my collaborators
and we actually try to compute it
in order to decide the vanishing of
these
invariants
um and it's fortunate because uh as i
said
of this g convexity you can compute it
to
arbitrary precision a lot in a lot of
cases
and some special cases
um
these uh there's a lot of a lot of
problems that sort of fall under this
umbrella
especially cool ones lately uh have been
you can compute brass comp lead
constants so it's constants and sum
inequality and analysis and uh
it turns out that
actually some
likelihood functions and statistics turn
out to be normal minimization problems
too um
and just a question
which i am curious about is uh
you know
here we have some optimization problem
which tells us
whether
uh two particular orbits intersect so
it's whether the orbit of v
and the orbit of zero intersects that's
what this uh
optimization problem here tells us
and what um i'm wondering is you know
is there
some analog if you have two arbitrary
vectors v and w
can you write down some tractable
optimization problem which tells you
whether those orbits intersect
um
because the orbit closure intersection
problem is a
an interesting problem in its own right
and it's but it's not uh
you know it's not solved except for
maybe except for in the abelian case
very recently
and i can just talk about the left hand
side a little bit
so what's this uh bombier norm
it's uh the way you define it is you
just define it as an inner product
so that if you evaluate p
on this like power of linear forms
um like think of you know a tensor power
of a vector as
a polynomial which means it's like a
certain linear form raised to the k
you just make sure that
p inner product with v sensor k is equal
to
the evaluation p of v
so it's really like if you
have ever thought of polynomials of
degree k as tensors
um it's the natural inner product there
but it's not gonna actually be important
for understanding this
okay so
um another way to think about this
quantity
is just as uh
an orthonormal um
basis of invariant polynomials evaluated
on your vector v so that's another way
to kind of measure the size of the
evaluations it turns out they're the
same
and another thing i should say is that
don't use the formulas
verbatim from this talk i probably am
missing you know constants of
dimensionality but other than that
hopefully they're fine
okay another way to think of this
is
as an average over a compact group
you don't really need to worry about
what k is but i would just have this
example in mind gln
and the unitary group
so you can think of this
quantity
of the average value of an invariant of
degree k
as a certain average of
uh this quantity over over the compact
group so like
average of the unitary group
and that'll come up in the proof
so here's um kind of an interesting
example in the abelian case
so maybe
i think a lot of people here will have
seen this matrix scaling problem
the group we're going to look at is the
pairs of diagonal matrices with
determinant one
and they'll act on complex matrices by
pre and post multiplication
and the question here usually is
you know can you choose x and y to make
a
uh doubly stochastic or at least
proportional to a doubly stochastic
matrix
it turns out that the
you know think about what the invariant
polynomials are they're going to be
polynomials which you know take in a as
input
and all they are is the uh
matching monomials which is like
um
you know maybe a11 a22 but then you
could have like a43 a34 and so on so the
product of those things like the
monomials that show up in the
determinant right
so it turns out that
for this particular degree
the expected value of the invariance of
degree
n
is exactly the permanent of the matrix
you get if you take the absolute value
squared of all the entries so the
permanent is one of these things
and that's uh par partly why i think
this is an interesting quantity
um because it it captures like neat
things like permanent in it
um and i'll just say that
well that's just degree in you can look
at other higher degrees
and you get these sort of higher
permanents
that barvanak and girvitz have talked
about
basically what they are is instead of
well the permanent you can think of as
summing up a
matching monomial evaluated on a matrix
the higher permanence you sum up
polynomials where every monomial comes
from
a
matrix where the row sums are all l and
the column sums are all l so it's like
higher degree monomials
and our theorem says that
the limit of these
higher permanents
is going to be equal to this matrix
capacity
which is the optimization problem you
try to solve when you try to make
this matrix
doubly stochastic
but i should say that in the abelian
case
our theorem turns out to be
the exact same thing as sanoff's theorem
on large deviations
uh and the right-hand side is just
the dual of the
minimum entry p problem that comes up in
cenops there
but i won't go into this connection much
in the talk
okay yeah and so i'll explain a little
bit like why there should even be a
probabilistic interpretation
so okay
before i go on any questions
all
right all right
question yes so for the open question
you mentioned yeah
is there any uh
stupid task but or it's part of the
question is there any way of writing it
as
using uh you know p1 of v and p2 of
w if you have v and w we want another
section of the orbit
yeah i mean i would even
use you could even use
one the same in variant right because
it's like the
orbit closures are going to intersect if
and only if every invariant matches on
those two
vectors right so i feel like there
should be something with uh
yeah the difference between invariants
on the on bmw
all right
so
now i'm going to explain
why
this uh quantity
is
should be interpreted as a probability
um
so
it's going to be the chance that some
real valued uh random variable
s is 0. so r in this in here is just
going to be the dimension of the group
we're looking at
pretty much always for the rest of the
talk you can think of it as being gln or
sln or
maybe some products of that
and this
letter s is going to stand for spectrum
estimation
but i'll explain why that happens soon
so quick
representation theory reminder
um
sticking to g being sln or gln
the
degree d or degree k irreducible
representation so that just means that
these are representations that don't
break up further and to direct sums of
more representations
they are
indexed by partitions
uh
lambda with
k boxes and in rows so this picture up
in the corner that's a pic a picture of
a partition with
i guess uh
10 boxes and three rows
the partitions you know think of them as
just
uh decreasing sequences of numbers of
integers with some k
each partition corresponds to a
particular irreducible representation of
sln
and we're going to denote that v lambda
and
you know one of the major
classic results in representation theory
is that
any finite dimensional representation
will break up into a direct sum of
irreducible ones
so you can write this as
a direct sum of irreducible
representations of some v lambdas
and
you can think of
you know imagine all copies
of v lambda of a particular one
corresponding to lambda
um the direct sum of those copies is
called the isotopic component of type
lambda
so it's basically
all the stuff that looks like the lambda
in there
and
we'll define this projection
to be
uh the orthonormal projection
to the isotopic component of type lambda
so you start with the big tensor power
or whatever and then you project down to
just the
direct sum of copies of v lambda so
that's what pi k lambda is
and we can use this to define a random
variable
s
the following way
so
to parse this first sort of ignore this
part this is just subtracting off some
of the all ones vector
but this part is what's interesting
basically we're going to say s is equal
to
some normalized version of lambda with
probability proportional to
actually equal to
the norm square of this projection
okay and why is this a probability
distribution well
maybe i should have said but v is going
to be a unit vector
so if you have
a bunch of projections which sum up to
the identity
and you take the
norm squared of their images and sum
those up that's going to be one
these pi k lambdas are
are such a set of projections because
the
v tensor carry breaks up into
irreducible representations
and
i won't go into the calculations or
anything but i'll tell you that
the probability that s is zero is
exactly this
um
random invariant
uh
quantity
and i mean the reason for this
is that uh
if this is zero
that means that lambda
the partition
was just a big box
right because we're taking lambda and
subtracting off the appropriate amount
of the all ones vector
and it turns out that
a big box that representation is just
the determinant
so it means that um
it's basically saying how many uh how
much of v
is projected down to the representation
that's the determinant
and the reason that the determinant is
um sort of has to do with invariance is
because we're looking at the group sln
and sln acts on the determinant
trivially
should it be lambda over n
uh
no it should be lambda over k i think
because k is the degree
um
okay we can do a sanity check so like
if you have uh
lambda being
a box with
uh
right each each row would have k over n
things in it
so you should get uh
maybe this patient be here yeah about
this so basically subtract off the
appropriate amount of the all one sector
thanks for the question
think of yeah lambda is just a vector in
rn so it's like this one would be
five four one
oh yeah so
okay so uh back to the angular momentum
example it turns out that
s will be the random variable
um where you take the
uh
the angular momentum
and put it you know negative in the
first coordinate and positive in the
second coordinate
and then divide by k so
in particular s being zero is the same
as the angular momentum being zero
um
okay so yeah also i didn't just make
this s thing up it's uh
a pretty well steady thing um
it's used in spectrum estimation in
quantum mechanics
and it's called the empirical young
diagram measurement for a particular
situation so that situation is when
gln acts on matrices by left
multiplication
so if
a is a unit vector
meaning its forbiddenious norm is 1
then
row is going to be a trace 1
psd matrix so we can think of it as a
mixed quantum state
and it turns out that
this random variable
sk
converges in probability to the spectrum
of row
so the reason this matters is that
given access to a bunch of copies of
this mixed quantum state which really
means you have access to row tensor k
you can sample
from this uh
random variable with one measurement of
that k copies
so you know otherwise uh
yeah it's not clear given a quantum
state how you measure it to determine uh
whether it's pure state or not so if
it's you know if it's a pure state that
means it just has it's rank one it has
one
non-zero eigen
value
the spectrum estimation measurement is
basically the best way people know of as
far as i know
to
figure out what the spectrum of the
quantum state is
um
and there's a further
refinement of this you can do
i'm calling another random variable t
for tomography
basically once you draw s
you can
draw another random variable u which is
going to be like some unitary matrix
and that's going to have the property
that when you conjugate the uh
you know the matrix with s on the
diagonal buy it
then actually that's going to converge
to the state itself
so
the moral of the story is that
you can estimate not just the
spectrum of the state but actually the
state itself
from
k copies of it
and actually it's
known
you know some bounds for how well it
works and it works pretty well um
okay
yeah and i should just mention that
t
is is kind of a quantum analog of
just the empirical
density function if you had just a
regular old probability distribution how
would you sort of estimate what the
density was say it's like
on
just like n things
you would just keep sampling from it and
then take the empirical distribution you
got that would be your estimate so
t
is the quantum version of that
you know why it has to be so complicated
i don't know but
that's how i think about it
um okay so
my or the question
uh in this talk is
where do these random variables s and t
converge for general representations
right
this uh spectrum estimation situation
was just the simple very simple
representation it was
invertible matrices acting on other
matrices by multiplying
so you could have much more weird
representations
like the example i mentioned in the
beginning just any particle
or the conjugation action or so on
and we wonder where these random
variables converge
so some people have done
work on this before
as i said the abelian case is just
standoffs theorem on large deviations
um
basically
that's because in the abelian case
t
is just the empirical distribution
function and that's what sanoft's
theorem is about
um in terms of non-abelian stuff
some people have worked on this before
in the case that
this mixed quantum state is the identity
um
in particular duffield solved this
problem for arbitrary representations
and
i should note that if if uh if the state
is the identity
uh what this random variable s is going
to be
it's just going to pick out a particular
partition
with probability proportional to the
dimension of the isotopic component
so that's that's what duff field
actually did is sort of figured out
asymptotics for
the dimensions of the isotopic
components
and there's also
a well-known result that
if you take a random row so sort of row
corresponds to the vector v
if you take a random one um
there's this measure called the uh
deutscher mount heckman measure
and
basically
they've already shown that this random
variable s converges to this this uh
particular strange measure in that case
um
okay so before i tell you so that's what
we did in this
work is figured out where they converge
in general
so i'll give some motivation for for
what that is
so
what you might guess is that
well
we saw already that t
is sort of concentrated around zero
if and only if the norm is already
minimized at uh
at the identity
that was what i was saying at the very
beginning
because we already know that sort of
if g is uh if g dot v is minimized at
the identity
then
the uh
you know rate of decay
of the chance of getting zero
is zero so it's basically very likely to
be 0. so maybe you could hope that the
gradient
is
where it's converging to because if the
gradient is 0
then it's sort of morally converging to
0.
so it's not actually quite that simple
but it's really close
you just have to take some logs and x
put some exponentials in so it's like
it's actually the
geodesic gradient in this certain
geometry um
so i'm going to be using this quantity
mu v
all you do is you
uh
take the gradient at zero
of the log norm of e to the h dot v
um
and this quantity is called the moment
map in other literature
and a neat example is that
as i was saying
the gradient sort of encodes angular
momentum
so in the
angular momentum example
the moment map's going to be a two by
two matrix
and it's going to
be this linear combination of the
powling matrices
where the coefficients are the expected
angular momentum
so here's some more examples
so in
the spectrum estimation case the moment
map is just the quantum state itself
and in the um
another example the
if you have a a product of three
glns acting on a
a unit vector
by
tensor products so g1 g2 g3 acts by g1
tensor g2 tensor g3 and so on
then the moment map is going to be the
uh one body marginals of this quantum
state row
so i won't explain exactly what this is
but um this is like the notation for
tracing out part of the
quantum state
so it's like if you have a quantum state
that's shared between three people alice
bob and carol
basically the marginals are
the three things that what alice sees
what bob sees what carol sees
um
okay so
here's our result about this
um
we showed that
um the variable sk converges in
probability to the spectrum of
the moment map so the moment map
remember it's the gradient and so it's
going to be
uh some matrix and the moment map
converges or the variable s
converges to the spectrum of it
and then this uh
tomographic measurement
converges actually to the moment map
itself
um
and then
you know we can do a very similar thing
to what we did in the first theorem
where we express any
uh particular probability limiting
probability
as
some norm minimization problem
but unfortunately it's like a little bit
complicated to write down what that
problem is but still
it immediately just
tells you that it's sort of
decidable to
um
you know approximate this
deterministically
to with any any uh precision you want
um and this picture is just sort of what
the measure looks like if you
uh
this joyster mount heckman measure where
if you select a row randomly
okay any questions about the results
yeah
so
two slides ago
uh
you have the first example of a geodesic
gradient with the volumetricity yeah
all right let's see
so what is the geometry there that's so3
uh this is youtube
so the this is the gradient along su 2.
um
it's actually so the
so yeah so you have um so su 2 is like
um
this is sort of this compact group
and then you have
this
bigger group sl2
and this is where the optimization is
happening
so we're looking at the uh
this norm where this guy is in
sl2
and it turns out you only need to bother
looking at
um sort of positive semi-definite g
the reason is you know this is the same
as uh v
g transpose g v right
so you only need to sort of look at a
positive semi-definite g here
and the way we're going to parameterize
this is just think of this as like e to
the h
and we can choose h to be traceless
first
h equals zero
um
so basically what we're looking at is
the gradient
uh
for
at h equals zero along
h being traceless 2x2
and then i guess i took a log
but in general
where you're going to be taking the
gradient that's a good question
where the gradient is going to live
uh it lives
in
i
times the lead group uh lee algebra of
this compact subgroup
so
su2
um is going to be the traceless the lia
algebra is the traceless anti-hermitian
matrices
so
it turns out that right we're taking the
gradient
in the traceless
permission matrices
sorry if that's a little confusing but
yeah this is this is where the the
um
the eye is the traceless thing what's
the i
this i yeah this i um
right the the way the moment map is
defined
over gln i should have said that this is
the
over the hermitian matrices so i turns
the anti-hermitian matrices into the
hermitian matrices yeah
right i mean the way to think about this
is like
you know
you can uh
sort of move in
both the
uh
you can move in the lique directions and
you can move in the highly k directions
and the leakage directions just rotate
things
the eye leak directions actually dilate
stuff and make the norms
smaller or larger
thanks to the question
anything else
right
so the way we think about this is
actually um
it tells you the sample complexity of
estimating the moment map itself so the
moment map is
often kind of an interesting quantity
and our result tells you exactly what
the asymptotics are for
this sample complexity
you know it's sort of weird that
it's in terms of some optimization
problem which you don't have a closed
form for
but
uh
that is the answer so i can't do
anything about that um but
uh yeah and and i guess in
in quantum tomography uh a lot of times
people care about estimating only some
certain linear
functionals of the state um the moment
map is an example of that
and you know in shadow tomography you
hope to get a lot better sample
complexity
so this is one way i think about this
this result
yes
so
the subtle complexity of
estimating u of the
originally
right
you can compute or approximately using
the
algorithms
so what yeah what do you mean exactly
what does that mean
right right so
i mean it in the uh
like
the sense of uh quantum like quantum
information so
you that's right if you have v
it's how you're given access to v so the
way we access b
b
um
basically by taking quantum measurements
so you're not given v in terms of like
you're not given all the coordinates of
all the entries
you
v is some unit vector in some vector
space and the only way you have access
to it is to you know yeah take quantum
measurements of it so you sort of
getting some
uh noisy access to
to v
so the the the problem is about how you
would estimate the moment map
if you
uh you know
didn't really have access to v you just
had quantum access to it
um
i guess maybe one interesting
use
or just use
that's right yeah in order to get sort
of results for decay you would need to
have some
um
you know
reason that the
capacity was uh sort of
decaying around that point
um like
like you have mu and you want to say
that the probability of getting
uh outside here is very small
you would need to have some bounds for
why um why the capacity shrinks out here
actually uh we do have bounds like that
um
this is just the uh basically this
we have some bounds that say like the
capacity of a vector v
is less than some
constant
one minus the some constant times the
norm of the moment so this basically
says that
you get some very
uh concrete like rates of convergence
for these
estimators
now maybe one reason you might care is
because in the algorithms for
the
norm minimization problem
you need access to this quantity mu so
if you only had
um so maybe you wanted to run a quantum
algorithm
or minimizing the norm
well you would only have you know
access to the vector as a quantum state
so you could try to estimate it you know
as a quantum state
um
estimate mu and then use mu in the
algorithm
but i haven't sort of explored
those
things
okay other questions
yeah
so um
spectrum estimation related
basically they're all spect they're all
special cases of this moment that
destination
um they're just different special cases
so uh spectrum estimation is the case
where you have
uh v
being you know the n by n matrices
v
is the
general linear group and the action is
you know g dot some matrix a is just
ga
so in that case the moment map
is actually just
a a transpose
and this is how you were parameterizing
the state u
basically the the angular momentum
problem is just
any uh any time that your group is su 2.
um
so i won't talk too much about the
proofs um but i'll give a quick sketch
um
so
i'm going to sweep a lot of the
pre-processing under the rug so this is
inequality one approved remember
um i'll just say that
it's enough to prove this whenever the
right hand side is equal to one
and the vector that you started with is
equal to one which means that the right
hand side is already minimized
and this gradient the moment map is
equal to zero
the reason for this is because
uh these quantities are both sort of
invariant under the group action the
left hand part is invariant because all
these polynomials are invariant the
right hand part is invariant because if
you act on v by some vector by some
group element you can change variables
so you can sort of
move things around until the moment map
is zero
okay and we just need to show that uh mu
v being zero
implies that this limit is equal to one
um so what that means is that you need
to show that
if the map is zero
you are
getting a bunch of
you have many invariants which are
substantially large on that
on that yeah
and the proof of this is kind of like
the
fourier analytic proof of the local
central limit theorem
um in the sense that
we're going to be just looking at some
interval
so we're going to use this formula
which i already mentioned which is that
it's equal to some average over the
unitary group
and
we need to show that
this is
decreasing um
not too fast so a one over poly k lower
bound will suffice because remember
we're taking this all to the one over k
at the end
uh and what we're going to do is
um i guess you could call it the
stationary phase approximation
we're going to show that
for a hermitian matrix h
right you can write down any uh unitary
matrix as e to the ih
and we're just going to show that for
oh sorry this should say h approximately
zero probably just a typo for h being
close to zero
this thing looks like a gaussian
and then in the end
you can estimate the integral for
h mu zero which means u close to the
identity by some gaussian integral and
you can just totally write down what
that quantity is and it satisfies this
and then you show that for
you far from the identity
this is just small so
uh the
inner product of u dot v is less than
0.9 and when you raise that to the k
that's going to decay exponentially
and then this you know unitary group
well the whole
volume of it is uh is is
finite so this if this were to work it
would be enough
um of course bonding a bunch of details
and it turns out that this
thing is not really going to be true
you might have some directions you can
go in the unitary group
that fix v
the vector
um
so if once you mod out by those you sort
of replace this by
modding out by this the stabilizer of
the vector
then this proof strategy works
um
okay
questions about this it's pretty good
yeah
it's actually not very important um
zero come in is it getting the
stationary case
that's right
it's here
um
because basically the uh if you took the
taylor expansion to this
like the first
uh
the first order stuff that would be the
moment
all right
so um
i just want to mention a connection to
um
that conjecture uh
it's called the tube conjecture and
uh the two conjectured it because it
implies this
um jacobian conjecture which i'll mark
about a minute but
what this conjecture says is that it
looks at a very similar quantity it's
the only difference is that you have two
different vectors here
and it says that if this quantity
vanishes for all k
then also for any other two vectors
for all but finitely many k this
quantity also vanishes
okay so
i admit that this doesn't look very
meaningful it doesn't look very
meaningful to me um at least
but uh
it implies this other conjecture which
is
sort of neat and old
that if a polynomial function
on the complex vector space has constant
non-z or jacobian determinant
it
has a polynomial inverse
um
and
i think that the connection is basically
that you know we proved that if v equals
w we basically proved a formula for this
uh this is just because
of that formula i mentioned that this
random variant is equal to this
average of the unitary group so we
proved a formula
um
and but but if you plug in two different
vectors
our proof breaks down and you know i
don't know what what this is
um and this is so this is the quantity
that they care about in the two
conditions
um so what i wonder is is there a way to
characterize this
um quantity
maybe it's like what uh the gentleman
over there mentioned that you know it
has to do with the differences between
invariants or something like that
um and in the abelian case the mature
conjecture has been proved and like they
used a formula a lot like this
um so so what i'm hoping is that
you know
this
function f of v and w has something to
do
with the distances between the orbit
closures
of these two different vectors
but no
i don't know i don't really have
anything in this direction
okay
uh yeah questions about this
previous
uh slide
but this one yeah
it's like the group visit
we
yeah actually it's uh
the two conjecture in the b equal w case
is true
um and it's like you don't you don't end
up needing the formula uh in that case
it's like a
it actually has to do with the moment
polytopes
yeah
do you get anything useful if you just
try to write this uh
[Music]
inner product to the power k down in
terms of the entries that you and grind
out the weingarten calculus
um i actually don't know what the
weingarten factor is like
there's a there's a general machinery
for computing expectation values of
polynomials and the entries of the
unitary matrix with respect to the
armature
i think that's what people do to get
special cases of this conjecture so i
think it's maybe been
okay i saw a paper that was looking at
it over uh
su-2 and they didn't prove it but they
said like here's it's promising because
of these calculations we don't know how
to really do weingarten tactile science
youtube we only know how to do it on you
okay
well
seems like maybe uh
a good good idea
yeah yeah so the general conjecture is
actually that
you're supposed to be able to uh plug in
any uh
yeah the general setup is a following
thing it's like
uh you have some nice group g which i
mentioned it needs to be like some
reductive groups so sln or something
like that
yeah it's a
you know complex connected um
it's it's going to act like
algebraically on on the vector space b
um
and then this you have this group k
sub here which is like a maximal compact
subgroup
so you can replace u n with this
maximal complex sub k and that's the
generality that the conjecture's on but
i think it's not known for
already these interesting
cases but smaller
okay
um
yeah so so open questions um
uh michael and i are actually looking at
this a bit right now is that
you know we have a formulae for the the
rate of decay
of this uh
random variable so basically how well
it's concentrated so these are like kind
of like turn off bounds
but you could hope for
uh sort of much finer control
in the range where the moment map is on
the order of root k so you could hope it
like decays gaussian lee
there
there are quantum
local central limit theorems but as far
as i know they don't
they're very different looking
so that would be something to look into
and obviously as i was saying
you want to understand this
metoo conjecture
and another thing um which i'll mention
is
that
sort of we gave large deviation
principles for this event um
that this tomographic measurement was
equal to a particular thing
but
it wasn't in terms of uh entropy
minimization problems it was in terms of
norm minimization so one thing i've
wondered for a long time is
is there some sort of relative entropy
like thing
between maybe vectors or maybe you need
to put the quantum states here or
something
where
the rate of decay is equal to
the least relative entropy
of some vector w such that the moment
map
is the right thing
um
but i don't know of such a thing
yes
it does that that's why it's uh equal to
or like that happens from the connection
with standoffs here in the apn case
it's also like this
thing in matrix scaling where you know
this
capacity which is this
problem you solve
to get doubly stochastic scalings
is also equal to like an entropy
minimization problem
okay i think that's it
thanks
one minute
and the next talk will be in the happen